[موسيقى]
الاخبار اهلا بكم نفه المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه تصريحات مسؤولين
ايرانيين بشان التوصل لاتفاق تبادل سجناء
ووصفها بانها كذبه اخرى اضافنا بلاده تعمل
من اجل تامين اطلاق سراح الامريكيين
الثلاثه المحتجزين بشكل جائر فيران على حد
تعبيره
مقابل عربه الخارجيه الايرانيه عن
استغرابها لرده الفعل الامريكيه مؤكده
توصل الى اتفاق لتبادل السجناء العام
الماضي واشارت الى تبادل رسائل عبر وسطاء
مع واشنطن لتحديث الاتفاق ودعت الخارجيه
الايرانيه الى عدم توظيف قضيه السجناء
السياسيا وكان وزير الخارجيه لرني قد
اعلنت توصل الى اتفاق لتبادل السجناء مع
واشنطن خلال الايام الماضيه
نقلت فانجل تايمز عن مصر دبلوماسي غربي ان
هناك زخما جديدا لامكانيه تبادل اسره بين
طهران واشنطن واضافت الصحيفه ان المناقشات
لا تزال جاريه لشل الافراج عن الاموال
الايرانيه
اكد رئيس شركه فاجنر العسكريه الروسيه
الخاصه
ان الوضع في بخموت صعب للغايه وان القوات
الاوكرانيه تدفع بامدادات اللانهايه لها
اضاف بريجوجل على حسابه في تيليجرام انه
مع تقدم القوات الى وسط بخ وتزداد المعارك
دروه
اجرت القوات الاوكرانيه تدريبات بالقرب من
الحدود البيلاروسيه ركزت على تدريب الجنود
على الاعمال الهجوميه من خلال محاكاه ظروف
القتال الحقيقيه وقالت وكاله رايتنز انه
تم تدريب العسكريين على تطهير المباني
وتغلب على العوائق واقتحام مواقع العدو
حسب الوكاله
فده مراسل الجزيره نقلا عن مؤسسات الاسرى
الاقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه اعتقل 13
فلسطينيا في انحاء الضفه الغربيه وكان
الجيش الاسرائيلي قد اعلنت لو قتل ثلاثه
فلسطينيين واعتقل رابعا خلال الشباك
المسلح عند مفرق قريه جيت قربه نابلس
قال الرئيس
ادارته عملت على معالجه المشاكل التي
يواجهها بنك سيليكون فالي وبنكشر وشدد
بايدن على التزامه بمحاسبه المسؤولين عما
وصفها بالفوضى وصلت الجهود لتعزيز الرقابه
على البنوك الكبرى واعلنت وزيره الخزانه
الامريكيه ورئيس الاحتياطي عن اجراءات
استثنائيه لوقف تدعيه المحتمله انهيار بنك
سيليكون فالي بما في ذلك دعم مبدعين لدوله
قال باسم او قال المتحدث باسم صندوق النقد
الدولي الصندوق يراقب تدعيه انهيار البنك
على الاستقرار المالي العالمي
بلاده ستعمل على تعزيز امنها القومي
للحفاظ على استقرارها واكد رئيس الصيني
رفض بجيل للتدخلات الخارجيه في ملف تايوان
ووصفها بالانشطه الانفصاليه الراميه
الاستقلال الجزيره
ختام الى اللقاء